[Music]
40 seconds left in overtime Anthony
Davis efficient what Davis didn't waste
much time and catching and going veteran
last year his contract he has instead of
just turning his nose being disappointed
at the young guy coming in to take
Steven Adams I'm going to show you the
ropes you show everybody what you got
those 13 points and 13 boards walked the
whole way up the floor by McConnell
[Music]
defensively getting the deflection the
steel and
- Ben Simmons for the strong finish
[Music]
records broken today on Christmas Day
[Applause]
Ricky Rubio with a great decision just
to commit a little bit I gotta pay
attention there that's awful
throws it away
Jones - Cutler
[Music]
oh I see you the love game that's so
effective between he had dreams heart
break - hunter deep capela sit in the
Sapphire he feels like his guy is hung
up rotation a little bit late this is
where a capella that pass right between
the defender great defense does it again
14 of his 25 have come here in the
fourth quarter
throwing ten assists shooting team have
a night like that I'm gonna give some of
the credit to the Nuggets defense games
prize and finishes
look at the judgment by the Cavs eight
to shoot poked away by animus to be
pardoned to the rap
gets his hand right there nice ball and
we know nobody's gonna respect that
plate
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy would devise the ball first of
all a beautiful split of the screen and
roll then description what up and - boy
Adam left codes you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report